tras llegar al baño del aeropuerto de
París chat de gold el primer gesto de
papel filiatiff fue simbólico
Aquí está mis papeles mi cartilla
militar rusa basura
mi pasaporte ruso basura
amo a Rusia y a mis compatriotas rusos
pero Putin y el gobierno no son Rusia
Putin Vete al infierno
las 48 horas en un centro de detención
El joven de 34 años ahora considerado un
desertor recibe permiso para entrar en
Francia y está trabajando con un abogado
para obtener el estatus de asilado su
testimonio arremete contra la guerra del
presidente Vladimir Putin en Ucrania
los rusos y los ucranianos nos matamos
entre nosotros pero también matábamos
civiles muchos civiles no podía aceptar
lo que estaba pasando y vamos a un
pueblo y lo destruíamos todo
soldado de élite estaba dispuesto a
morir por su país pero tras dos meses de
guerra en el frente Consideró que la
invasión no tenía sentido
hoy en día Muchos soldados rusos se
niegan completamente a ir a la guerra y
los que van no tiene motivación por eso
puten trata de recluir a los prisioneros
y a los ancianos
mientras estaba en el hospital hablando
de la desorganización del ejército Ruso
y de las matanzas irracionales un sitio
web de su país publicó extractos para su
relato y el canal de YouTube de un grupo
defensor de los Derechos Humanos Le
invito a hablarlo Solo quiero que la
gente vea la verdad y los hechos cuando
encienda la televisión oirán a Rusia
decir que está librando a Ucrania de los
nazis me he enterado de que mi mando ha
pedido una condena de 15 años contra mí
acusándome de difamar al ejército fue
una razón suficiente para huir me
convertí en una amenaza para ellos
temiendo por su vida pasó un mes fugado
antes de ser ayudado a salir a
escondidas por los denunciantes tras
llegar a Francia Hace unos días piensa
pedir asilo y protección policial